let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 we will start with our caller from
the 907 area code caller from 907 if you
can hear me
go right ahead introduce yourself tell
us who you are hello this was Desmond
I'm from Anchorage Alaska great go ahead
Desmond and my question has to do with
the electoral college and from what I
what I have read it there is a lot of
flaws with it and I've seen that there
is like 30 states including the District
of Columbia that has some sort of law
that has electoral colleges have to vote
with their constituents but from my
understanding only 21 of those states
don't face a penalty correct me if I'm
wrong you know I don't know the
specifics of that but what I do know is
that the way around this the simplest
way around this would be the national
popular vote interstate compact whereby
states can decide to award their
electoral votes their delegates to the
winner of the National popular vote and
then you would sort of create a de facto
popular vote but I can't speak to the
specific laws that you're talking about
okay and another question that is also
do with electoral colleges with all the
flaws with it if we are would you prefer
fixing all the flaws and making it more
like possible that it'll be guaranteed
that the popular vote would guarantee
the presidential like candidate would
win the election or would you yeah or
would you rather take it away and have
it be more of a ranked choice voting and
it's all the people like it is with the
Senate elections state elections mayor
or etc yes
there's a couple different overlapping
things here that you're talking about
Desmond but big picture I would I think
that if we want to break the two-party
duopoly rank-choice voting or other
versions of similar to rank-choice
voting would sort of be necessary
separately from that I would like to go
in the direction of an effective popular
vote now actually getting rid of the
Electoral College constitutionally it
procedurally is quite complex I think
the simplest path to an effective
popular vote would be something like the
NPV I see and we will we will see
ultimately if we get any closer to that
but very very I'm glad Desmond's
thinking about this because we did do
the story about Trump being in favor of
going to the popular vote which I am in
favor of as well it would be a very
tough thing to do politically but if it
was ever gonna happen it would be now
because liberals are upset with the
electoral college it screwed them in the
two of the last five elections yep Al
Gore and Hillary Clinton and then I won
four - that's a partisan support right
there